welcome back to the Rich Eisen show fun
chat with jayjay want right there and I
turn to my right a guy I've known for
for a while but I haven't seen in quite
some time
and when his name started popping up on
our Instagram feed we're like let's get
him in just reconnect he's he's a
creator writer producer of the great hit
series entourage he is Doug Yellin good
to see you sir thanks for having me he
got a brother so let's get right into
this how did how did entourage come to
be that's there was really Wahlberg
story in a way how did you his manager
was my manager Steven Levinson I'm with
the college with it came to me said we
want to do a show about a movie starring
his friends right I hated the idea I did
I thought it sounded ridiculous and then
Steve Levinson said to me he's like
you'll figure it out and I went home I
didn't really have a job anyway so I
started thinking about it and figured it
out so what didn't you like about the
idea to begin with um I you know I'm I
don't live that kind of like sycophantic
lifestyle of living off somebody else so
I just didn't really see it and what I
what I took home to myself was figure
out how to make it a family and give
everybody some type of purpose
driver the assistant whatever so right
and so when did Wahlberg come in was he
there was always him to begin it's in
the beginning it was Mark and Steve they
came to me so I there really wasn't much
of anything else to go on just like we
wanted a show about a movie starring his
friends right and we started looking for
a mark guy which was impossible to find
and ultimately it started shifting and I
switched it to New York and started you
know modeling it a little bit on my
friends also so okay and so when was the
first time you met Wahlberg when was
that
well I knew mark four years before the
okay someone was the first time you met
him I think the first time I met him
actually I had dinner with him at a
place called Giorgio somebody a friend
of mine was in traumatic town and said
these two young up-and-coming stars
right somehow I had to dinner with Mark
and Leonardo DiCaprio when I was like 21
and you know I have no idea how that
even happened but is
dinner I want to know what happened
after dinner I went home was this in the
day when when Wahlberg was adding an
ordering extra bread to the table and he
was doing every water itself man I can't
believe his routine is just in yeah I
mean it's unreal yeah it's like we all
don't get up and shower at 2:00 in the
morning for our 3 a.m. workout very
driven guys I guess so so and so the
guest star list on that show was absurd
so at some point when did you finally
start getting calls where people like I
want to be on that show like season two
or three I mean the first season it was
impossible to get anybody you know even
mark I didn't know if he was gonna show
up he was in the pilot and I had no idea
if he was actually coming or not are you
serious yeah we had one actor who did
not show up for the pilot and Adrien had
to start calling friends to get somebody
down so it started out very tough and
then by the end it was great I'm sure
you got calls so then which is the call
that you got that was particularly like
okay now I know where we've made it what
was that um LeBron probably you know and
I gotta call the brown wants to do a
show what I meet them and the bran says
you know this is my E this is my drama
this is my turtle it was very cool
no kiddin yeah all right now how did
Brady wind up on that show well Brady
which is it's kind of a sad tragic story
how Brady ends up on the show the ending
obviously is triumphant an amazing but
after the Giants win the Super Bowl and
I'm a die-hard Giants fan Eli Manning
calls me says he wants to be on the show
and I said well then you're on the show
I've write a script which you know it
may look like this is you know no big
deal easy but I've read a script with
Eli and then his agent at one point
called said Peyton he'll do it too so I
write this whole script and then we're
getting ready to shoot about six months
later and I I called
Eli on his cell how he called me and he
doesn't return my call and then I had
Jerry called and he hasn't returned
Jerry's call so Ferrara you got him cry
I had Ferrara call I brought in the big
guns you know and then I'm in the office
and I'm losing my mind because now we're
like a couple of weeks out and I have to
you know brothers who there was some
comedy relating Vince and drama to them
I'm like I don't know how to replace
these guys like we get the Sharpe
brothers I don't know we're good there
and and Marc happened to be at the
office and I'm I was tended to be a
little crazy and was freaking out
throwing things around the office of
Marc's like what's the problem Marc's to
come as cool this guy I'm like I don't
know what to do we have no one to shoot
this was like what if me and Brady do it
I was like well that works you know to
me Tom Brady is honestly one of the a
one of nicest guys but also the way he
carries himself and when we shot
you don't usually give like these stars
these 7 a.m. call times you try to make
it a little easier but Tom shows up at 7
a.m. it's like 40 degrees at the golf
course that was looking out he walks out
grabs a club and takes one and hits it
220 and misses a hole-in-one by like a
year and that was complete movie star
epic moment so he's born to do it yeah
just in any single damn thing he puts
his mind to
yeah so he's on the show cuz Wahlberg's
like I'll save ya I'll save the whole
show I got it I got the script at the
for you and so I'll just call Brady and
then Brady you know more importantly
guys Eli bit of a big-time diva Wow
wants to try and you know I mean one of
the great you know interviews that I
have on tape somewhere is mark and Brady
and they asked why Eli was on the show
and Mark gave an answer that would never
ever be able to be put out there but
Tom's face was dying and you know it
still it was tough for me as a Giants
fan and but since then you know I'm
still a Giants fan but I've always
rooted you know Julian did the show and
then you know and your Pronk did it so I
root for them you're partial to people
who who are good to me yeah Doug Allen
here on the Rich Eisen show so how did
you become a Giants fan I became a
Giants fan
I was said on the radio portion earlier
I was a Rams fan because of the movie
something for Joey which was about John
cappelletti and I said you know movie
that makes young men cry which I did and
I was a Rams fan but then I'm like
twelve years old I think and my
brother's going to college in Pittsburgh
and I'm in the hotel they're the Giants
are staying there and I'm playing
asteroids and the team walks in and this
one guy comes up and says
can i play with you kid I was like sure
and I'm playing with him he's great guy
we're hanging out and I know he's a
player I asked for autograph and it's LT
and that was his rookie year I really
didn't know who he was but I'm like
alright this could be my guy I'm gonna
follow him and you know and it all came
full circle twenty years later or and lt
follows me on Twitter I was like wow
this is this is pretty great so hold on
so you're playing asteroids decides the
time where they were they playing the
Steelers I guess preseason so and this
is a guess I'm trying to think what the
year that is this gonna be like late
seventies early eighties asteroids is
pretty big asteroids is amazing I mean
oh is that status game I mean oh I guess
another one but the other way to put it
is well solvers playing space invaders
with phil simms we're in this town I'm
asking you these questions and it's just
amazing how these out in Pittsburgh this
is not a Hollywood story and I'm just a
kid you know and I didn't know who he
was at the time and you know he
obviously became who he became so it's
pretty wild and you're from Long Island
you know which makes you an Islanders
fan right I grew up again I'm 50 so I'm
I mean you and I aren't too damn far
apart so I grew up a ranger fan yeah and
I loved the Rangers in in the mid to
late seventies Ron do gay with his
flowing hair every one of them I mean
and we're in my pod venture is the in
Madison Square Garden having things
thrown at me when I was 9 or 10 years
old that makes it tougher just makes you
tough it's over maybe whoo I remember
watching the drive for 5 you know on my
local whatever cable TV like maybe
Wilmette go at it or something like that
and I just remember I hated the island
I hated Nystrom I hated bossy I hated
Smith Billy Smith was the biggest punk
goalie dirty was filthy dirty I thought
and I was at though I was at the eighty
game Nystrom scores I'm in the last last
row of the Nassau Coliseum and this was
right by far the greatest sports moment
I've ever experienced come on it was I
mean I was such as I said earlier I
could name pretty much every name and
number of everyone on that team okay you
know so if you know 23's Nystrom
obviously and he said basi 22 and Smith
31 but I mean I mean like there's no
memory that's even close to that and the
feeling when they won you know I always
all I wanted for my kids was to be able
to experience that when they grew up and
it doesn't seem to me that the passion
is as much anymore as it was when you
lived and breathed these teams there you
know that kind of they lived in the
community see him around then it was
just very cool really you just see him
around
you know Ben's delicatessen there's
Gordon Lane sitting there you know are
you serious I mean I don't know that I
saw a Gordie Lane actually so have you
followed them to Brooklyn are you still
an Islanders fan I'm still an island fan
I couldn't name everyone's number today
we just said I could I did still have a
very big out I mean you know it's um
it's amazing seeing them in Brooklyn now
might the first concert I ever went to
was at Nassau Coliseum - Joe I I'll be
honest with you I well I'm always
shooting everybody straight here kind of
wish it was Billy Joel who's now as you
know the official singers Madison Square
Garden you know it was Chicago it's a
good show well I mean it was the it was
the of the hard habit to break a
[Music]
comedian opened up my god bus my late
dad drove drove our asses all the way
out there I drove around
like three hours and then picked it up
and drums back there was cell phones
like this is back when we're calling
sports phone to find out the scores it's
very sad now it's changed my parents
would never have let me do the stuff
that goes on I know man Wow Doug Allen
here on the Rich Eisen show ok so that
you're a Knicks fan now right I'm a
Knicks fan all right I produced the
documentary on the 69 to 72 Knicks you
know I don't want to put you in a
difficult position because I'm very very
critical of the owner very ver and I put
money and I hate his guts how can you
not I mean it's it's horrible to see
this and when you think you know that
the Knicks are now this destination that
no one will go to when they have the
money it's mind-boggling I mean you know
I you know Baron Davis is a friend of
mine and when when Baron they had a
minute.what Baron came in to the guard
and all of a sudden you felt the whole
NBA to me feels better when the Knicks
are good and to see that no one will
even go there now is it's tragic it just
is this is the best place in the world
and you know it's where I grew up
it's where I saw you know Bernard King
do his thing and let Jerry know Bernard
King Jersey in the pilot because Bernard
King was my idol
I worry about my turnaround jump shot
every day and my oh my god quite wasn't
quite Bernard well you know he went
back-to-back 50 points in Texas and then
there was the Pistons playoff series
where Isaiah and him basically played
one-on-one they I forgot what the total
number was 24 points in a row but
Bernard was the guy what a shame that
his knee blew up terrible I know
obviously that did lead to Patrick Ewing
winning the position that Knicks to go
get him or to have them but I mean they
played I think just a handful of games
together yeah
Ewing and Bernard King would have been
unbelievable leave a pair and Bernard is
so underrated as you know really what a
great offensive players of all time of
all time yeah there's no doubt about it
so that's where I flew that that's where
I I fell in love with basketball fell in
love with the next just even to this day
I haven't been to the Garden in years
and
again I'm not making too big of a deal
of it but I have been so critical of
this guy Dolan that we have a Dolan
wormhole there anytime I mention him I
just devolve into anything even like
again the NFL Draft is coming to Vegas
and it's gonna be amazing
and I say the reason why and then last
year in Nashville in the year before in
Philadelphia and it looks amazing the
person you have to thank for that is
James Dolan cuz he yelling in the NFL
out of out of Radio City Music Hall I
mean I can't believe the Kevin Durant's
not there I was I was a hundred because
if Dolan thought it was gonna happen and
not to make fun but it's like that
anyway they won't go to the Nets over
the New York Knicks certain generation
but that Barclays Center is a beautiful
spot Brooklyn is just across it is
Brooklyn is a great place but you still
would think you want to put on that New
York Knicks jersey let the Lakers you
would think you want to be in that and
you want to win a championship for them
but obviously not I guess there's Yanis
feel that way because that's the that's
there's no way yes I don't know that we
were talking today about Kenny Smith
coming in as the the GM I mean they
bring Mark Jackson and Kenny Smith maybe
things could change I don't I mean for
us just cuz we remember that yeah oh my
gosh no I know
absolutely absolutely at mr. doug ellin
on both Twitter and Instagram yeah
because I you know whatever we have
Jerry on I don't I don't want to put him
in a tough spot talking about the Knicks
and being critical and stuff like that
but well he gets the good seat so he
does get the good seats thanks for
coming on today really appreciate back
on any time at mr. Doug Allen on both
Twitter and Instagram 844 204 rich is
the number to dial for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app